[Music]
so what would you say to the people and
I probably should have asked you this
maybe 20 minutes ago because I think a
lot of people are watching this and
Galore it guys making a lot of sense but
there was a time when racism was
systemic so I'm sure you would argue
that youyou believe that there are
racist right that racism exists certain
amount of people don't like you because
you're black period and if a lot of
people don't like Asian people or gay
people or Muslim people or ever okay
there are bigots out there now it's not
built into the system anymore but do it
does the system oh anything to black
people for past grievances for the fact
that most black people that are here
were brought here not voluntarily I do
think they oh but how would you figure
it how would you figure this out I think
they all because I see what they did to
the Jews and they're continually paying
them in their generation if you don't
pay this group but you will pay that me
I like like Germany like what happened
reparations to Jews after holiday yeah
so if that can happen it's what happened
with the Japanese who were interned here
in a little while they were compensated
the Indians were compensated black
American have to be compensated for
something I would assume but then the
logistics of it who pays what where does
it go who actually had lineage because
if I'm not mistaken only 2 to 8 percent
of whites actually owned slaves but like
everybody had slaves so where are you
how do you calculate this money and who
actually gets it because not every black
person that's in America came from a
slave either and is there is there also
an inherent problem even if you did that
which I agree it would be an undertaking
that would be beyond an intelligible
right man but let's say you could figure
it out and you could get some consensus
on enough that we can get consensus on
anything America well let's say we get
some consensus on and people that said
O'Kane is basically right is the other
combat it actually feeds exactly what
you've been talking about is the biggest
problem here which is all right you
throw money at it you don't know what
people are going to do with their money
they'd be entitled to do whatever they
want with it
some people are going to buy a car some
people are going to waste it on booze
some people might invest it in education
all that but that you actually didn't
solve a problem you just sort of
you enriched victim culture which I know
sounds terrible in a situation like this
but that's kind of what you're doing
yeah Dave Chappelle skip did it
perfectly I don't know if you've ever
seen the skit where he was showing the
black guy reparations oh yeah yeah and
Cadillac sales went through the roof and
it was all ridiculous money throwing it
ridiculous stuff if you think about the
black community I think they did a study
and the GDP of blacks in America if they
separated out and became their own
country it would be the night wealthiest
country on the planet so that means
there's a lot of money going through the
hands of black people in America you
can't say it's not when they can spend
ten billion dollars a year on weave
alone I leave I've sort of got 10
billion dollars in billion a year in
Jamaica it's a 1 billion dollar industry
and they're poor so you have women right
now you will see women on Instagram and
they all look like they're rich because
they all got their weave in their hair
and they all do out there was a woman
during the riots of Flambeau castile who
was shot by the police his girlfriend
was there and she says stop burning CNN
did the whole they didn't hold back so
they do unbelievable right so they made
it seem like she was a victim and she
was saying go out to white people you
better get that part hey cut it was
every I was I believe that out real
quick and you're just laying it out real
quick because I didn't see it and we'll
put a link to it below good
it's unbelievable with it yeah I did
this video and they cut out the part
where she was saying go after white
people go out the white businesses we
need to go out to white people this is
during the ride during the ride and
she's standing up so she's inciting a
riot against white people
CNN had the footage 100% of the footage
they cut it to where it looked like
she's calling for peace but that isn't
what she was calling for she was saying
as black people don't do anything to
each other in our quote-unquote stuff
let's go do it to the white people and
they literally cut at the end of that
meaning oh and they made her out to be a
benevolent figure at this point or even
though she's grieving from the loss of
her companion she's called in calling
for peace but that isn't what she was
doing but one of the funniest things she
said was we need our [ __ ]
we need our weed and I keep playing that
backerboard like
what person said this this is a mother
these are women and if you look at most
riots or most of these so-called this
guy got shot or killed by the police you
look on the streets there's a bunch of
women and where all these women come
from all these things all these cities
where this violence is is overrun by
single black mothers who are raising
these children in these environment so
nobody's going to point out that single
black mothers in almost every violent
city across the United States
overwhelming real raising the children
that would be an immediate link if you
had a link to where every police chief
and every one of these cities were white
and all of the educators were white and
the kids were dumb and violent we would
say well look who's over them but we
won't do it when it comes to liberal run
cities and single mother runs
neighborhoods we will not point out that
that one link is everywhere and why CNN
helped perpetuate it that's why I don't
like liberals because they're
perpetuating the victimhood like you
said the low expectations you know
they're telling them hey you know the
SAT is culturally biased yet Sooyoung
who would years old when she came over
here you're a stick
how can people who've been here for four
hundred years if you've been under the
thumb of white people the one thing you
should know is the culture of white
people so that I should pass any test to
tell me what white people are doing Jeff
and murder and hangings I gather though
that has a mother
but we are saying to black people is
culturally biased but people who come
from another culture can ace the test
you're telling them that you can be no
more than what you currently are and
that's why you have generations of
poverty so you mentioned that you
supported Trump how powerful that when
he said in that speech when he talked
about race when he said what you had to
lose when I saw it live and I thought I
got what he was doing but I thought it
was it was just it felt to me and this
may be a little of my own liberal it's
not like a little too much to me because
it was like it was almost like you it's
so horrible for you when it's not
horrible for everybody obviously now
maybe he was talking about really he was
just owning in on the people that are
really
city's better he said under some of
these Democrat liberal policies and all
that stuff but I but you must have heard
that and thought holy [ __ ] he this is it
and I said it he's touching the mindset
remember what we talked to leading up to
here that you'll have someone like Jesse
Jackson come out and just speak or ass
off to speak to black people to say
you're doing horrible in America and
even if somebody is you think once you
got these rappers who got Bentley than
making songs about how they so rich it
and they'll be like yes you're right
we're having a horrible here so it's the
mindset of just because you're black
even when you're rich you're going to
have a poor mindset so and black people
can tap into that and get blacks to feel
like perpetual victims even when they're
doing well ie what Jesse Williams who
has a white mother stood up in front of
the Oscars and said we black people are
magic like what is your white mom do
when you're saying that she's like got a
gun like some other to tap her on the
shoulder think yeah he still might be
taking care of this like that you know
right everybody goes no but that's what
said it's a good thing to even have to
do that because half of you is black the
the whole of you is black and you have
to act like even your white side is feel
bad and then the white people because of
liberal guilt I just slept with the
black guy that's all I did and that was
my reparation like it's weird and you
watch this this whole dynamic that's
being put out there so I liked when
Donald Trump did it because they're
pushing that we all blacks have the same
experience you know if you're black the
comedian always talks about how rough
his childhood was and the crowd that you
know my mother used to beat me with a
curling iron my mom would beat me but I
like everybody's telling a story about
how physically abusive that childhood
house used to do the thing about his
wife's coming in with the broom beating
him like it was a hockey stick yeah so
violence is the thing in these
communities and everyone relates to it
so doll trunk did what they were doing
well since they all relate to this let
me ask them the question the heck I've
done it in Dayton I told a gray
I can't be any worse than decisions you
read in the back
and it works that were the hood yeah
little Louis make Texas yeah but if you
sit back and you think about it he had
to touch that I was glad that he said it
yeah because blacks are being told to
continue to vote Democrat but they're
getting nothing from it
the blackmail again while talking about
males from the one who gives a crap
about males the black male job
employment unemployment was up to like
twenty to some percent on the rock a lot
you talk about it been breaking up so
everybody was ok with black males I've
been a to get a job as long as black
females can get a job
we're the only culture in America that's
upside down meaning the women run this
society the women are the power brokers
the black community the men they don't
have power through the 80s and 90s black
women were going on TV show like Donahue
Jesse writes out Jesse Raphael saying
we're educated and we can't find any
good men because the black men are
either gay or in jail this was the 80s
and 90s Oh black boys how can you grow
up to want to be a man when all you hear
is I don't need a man you didn't even
want to be a man so Trump then you liked
it when you heard it now he has ben
Carson who's a neurosurgeon as the
health housing secretary which is a
little bizarre to me yes he didn't want
to be in it would have been his Surgeon
General he said it wasn't Halle five or
that women what I know this is a little
business Saturday right like he seems
like he would have been a little more
qualified for that than the housing
thing but okay I'll go with it by the
way you could see a tremendous amount of
that that soft racism with liberals
because Ben Carson who again the guy was
a pretty terrible candy he always looks
like he's sleeping you speak slowly and
all that stuff but then Trump hired him
so a black man now moves up you think
the Liberals would all be like this
but instead now he's a sellout and all
the stuff that you were saying that you
get called and all that so okay so
putting that aside so he's got ben
Carson and then he has Steve Harvey
kind of said you know you're going to
work with him and help University I
suspect they're actually going to do
something I think Trump is a businessman
and for all my reservations about him I
think he's probably going to have them
come up with some plan to go in there
and do it
have you seen any evidence about yet oh
here's a problem Steve Harvey had to
immediately switch right so turn against
Donald Trump because he again was
worried
being called a [ __ ] then had one of his
friends do usually call him out for just
meeting with the guy but just meeting
with him now mind you they praise dr.
Martin Luther King who just met with a
president so he did the president at the
time you didn't know what was going to
happen
he met with them and a lot of them were
using him to liberals were using him as
a well we're benevolent to Black's we
love them and behind the closed doors
they were saying we'll have the [ __ ]
vote Democrat for the next 200 years now
mind you they know this they understand
how the game is being played but they
turn this guy who just met with him
against him to where he had to become
one of his biggest allies I don't like
Trump now and and I just went there and
in the in there just to appease this
monolith called the Black Thought who
are we not even working with him
anywhere in this it was that oh really I
didn't even go that part so they're you
well because of what the backlash you
got from black people black people just
think like there's just one black guys a
little few of them there's supposed to
be these Pro black guys and they will
tell them black people don't vote in the
election your vote doesn't matter so
then don't Trump wins and they get upset
how's that make sense you literally told
people not to vote so why should you
care about the outcome as a black person
you telling black people do not vote
then you should not care about the
outcome by the way not all of this is
purely racial because even a guy like
the remember was at the uber CEO who met
with Trump and then got a huge backlash
so then he had to turn he stepped away
and said I'm not I'm going to be off the
Economic Advisory Council or whatever it
was so even that that goes to the the
mindset of these people that in some
ways supersedes race you're giving me a
racial example there but it goes to just
a general I think a lot musk said
something about that he said something
to the effect of guys he's pretty much
I'm loosely doing this but he was like
look he's president I can effect more
change if I'm in their rhythm rather
than just screaming about it so in a way
it's really just a complete lack of
maturity right like it's like if you
want to change things just screaming and
burning things down and you know
stopping speakers and all that nonsense
that doesn't do anything except in bold
in your enemies what does things is
actually sitting with people that you
don't like yeah and they were asking for
the liberal oven the Republicans to do
it on their
Barack Obama you need to sit down with
him and work with him they're making it
hard for when you're making it hard for
Trump and you're doing that on purpose
and you're doing it on loss all of the
Liberals are saying let's just make it
difficult for bi-lo to be on a campus
let make it difficult for tunning to be
on youtube let's make it difficult for
any voice that may even ask the question
because a lot of us are just asking the
question think about it we're not on the
streets beating anyone we're not
advocating the beating of anyone we're
asking the question is it as simple as
how its presented to us is it as simple
as Trump is a racist is it as simple as
Republicans with xenophobes it can't be
that simple cuz I don't know what a
xenophobe is but is it as simple of
these things and asking these questions
are shaking that tree and I guess the
people who are in that tree hiding don't
want to actually fall out so they're
going to do all I can and make you stop
shaking that tree the truth is what we
should in all of us should want as
American citizen and we all should want
our president to kind of succeed because
the president succeed in truly we will
succeed
right Sam Harris who was completely
against Trump wrote a piece after the
election or did a thing on his podcast
or he said look now the guy is the pilot
of the plane you want that plane to
crash I don't think so and he was 100%
against him mm-hmm
but we can't get that I think this is
what America's pushing this whole find a
way to divide people race class gender
and it all a lot of this stuff is
preferences like you can't even have a
preference around a liberal a liberal
homosexual says well you should accept
my lifestyle but if you say well I
accept your lifestyle I just don't want
my kid to be like well you're a bit wait
a minute I accept the fact that you want
to be homeless I don't want my kid to be
homeless I accept the fact that you want
to smoke crack I don't want my kid to
smoke crack and I have two daughters I
don't want them dating someone who's
poverty-stricken
what does that make me I don't
understand that we can't even have a
preference anymore when life used to be
about preferences and abilities I have
no problem with a white person saying
well my granddad was like grandma's why
the car I want my white kid to marry a
white person why is that a problem I
don't know that because that's going to
get you in a
a world of hurt for that that'll be the
clip that people take out of this and go
you see now he's lining with the white
nationalism everybody give a notice with
black people would said all the time
black means getting set up there I
wouldn't date a white woman he prays for
it he will say it in public so why is it
that we can say we want to keep our
black first and black businesses why can
we say that but if anybody else says it
it's wrong why can you have black pride
Brown pride gay pride but not white
progress that's racist what do we do
from here what do we do from here like I
think most people I think a lot I know a
lot of my audience is going to hear you
really hear you and go this is the type
of stuff that I think needs to be heard
more and I think that the group of
people that are talking about this stuff
is actually growing I do see this at the
same time the people who don't want to
hear us are getting more and more
hysterical because that's all they got
left where do you see all this going
especially in the framework of having
Trump as president we have to have more
dialogue like this I think when people
see you and me you and I oh well I'm
sure there was a systemic reason that
you rise because of the weighted racism
workers factor but if you would ask me
if they got all the linguistic things
that I screw up here I would would not
be pretty good if people won't people
like you and I Crowder and all of us are
Mark Levine all of us just got together
it doesn't matter what side wrong if we
could just have the conversation because
Bill Maher used to be good at saying
let's just have the conversation and I
still like that he will call out those
idiots on the liberal on college
campuses but it's kind of the only we
need to call them out is because they've
affected him in any way so as long as
they don't affect him and his work
you'll side with them but if more of us
can have these conversations and not
have them in Jerry Springer style
formats to where it's your liberal and
I'm a conservative we're going to fight
because we have more in common than the
world wants us to believe the bigger pit
the powers-that-be
they're wanting us to not have real
dialogue they're wanting black people to
feel like white people are against you
you owe me something Michael Eric Dyson
so yes these white people should pay
maybe you should give black people a
computer
Earl I was there that on Delamar I would
do that where you get my fur he said it
before you know he said only longer I
was there that night in the audience and
I said I saw this everyone applauded
when he said it and I'm watching this
woman there was like a 16 year old white
woman in front of me applauding yet you
should give a computer to receive it you
should give a computer to a black hand
I'm looking around all these people are
put there's virtually no black people in
the crowd I made maybe a couple but it's
all white people it was about I'm
looking around on are any of you going
to give a computer to a black person
like you're all just doing it so you
think you feel good about you know
you're not really doing it but I saw
that line and I thought bill was going
to go for him on it and they let it go
they just let it be and I know as an
interviewer sometimes you let some
things go it's just the nature of
talking to people and for him he has you
know time to church to the lab but I
just thought it was hilarious give a
black kid a computer like I run around
go boy you take my phone let me ask you
there's a white person in the audience
yes did you kind of look around and see
it is he joking like is this a part
where we laugh or is he seriously saying
everyone applauded so quickly that there
it was a joke it was I don't will we
know wasn't a joke but you know cuz I
would have thought as a white person but
maybe he's playing with us right now
because that makes no sense that we just
walk out and give a random black kid a
computer for the Dublin by the way for
the record in his defense he was saying
that he didn't believe that reparations
were necessary in a traditional form he
was saying what you could do in your own
personal right but in a way that made it
funnier because then you have all them
applauding and you know that none of
them are giving away their at Macbook
yeah nobody's doing that everybody
talking about the iPhone just give it
out when you walk out of here just you
want me to put a black key with that I
got three of them I promise I can I get
what do you think what the funny thing
is you're offering something to black
kids that they already have even when
they're poor they already have access to
the in and at half of Twitter with black
people even only 13% of a society is
black there's been a lot of time online
how do you think I keep getting flag
that it's not a shortage of black people
of life so why they offering them
something that they can't use something
that is going to make what they're doing
already worse there's a movie out called
or it's coming out this summer called on
girls trip starring Queen Latifah I just
want you to go and watch the
trailer for its own the most disgusting
trailers ever of these middle-aged black
women saying other sexually perverse
stuff and it's a trailer for a movie and
I'm watching I felt I could see myself
sinking into my feet so the movie
theater with a bunch of white people and
they were laughing - they love to see
those black girls be sassy that's
ruining our community and having a movie
about them going around and having
irresponsible sex why would you need
that in a group that's filled with STDs
and single motherhood why would you
teach this how would that be the movie
you put out because there's a mindset
that's being pushed by these liberals to
tell blacks basically liberals are like
the pets of black of blacks or the pets
of liberals just like to have us around
so as long as they can feel above us
then it's cool because I've heard more
racist comments come from liberal rights
to conservative whites and it would be
all over small disagreements or
ideologies and I'm thinking surely you
could agree with me what I call them you
n-word because you're liberal right so
that's how you're acting so they'll
justify and I'm like well wait a minute
but you're supposed to be above this but
apparently they're not when it comes to
disagreement of ideology yeah listen we
could go on and on but unfortunately I
got another interview to do so we're
going to leave it I didn't look down
once which I always say is a good time
of a solid interview so one more thing
for you and then I'm going to direct
people to where to find you but we don't
even know these places are going to
exist by the time we post this because
YouTube's bumping your head Twitter's
bumping and everything else you are
doing a movie about this right you raise
some money on a movie yeah called a
fatherless America and it should be out
this summer and looking forward to that
we're talking about and not just blacks
just a fatherless America how fathers
are being pushed out of the lives of
their children and it's become a norm
that a child does not need is father
when you are married to a woman you see
it kids every day you go divorce you see
your kids every other weekend how's that
fair that the judge goes into and the
mother has to be a complete horrible
parent for the father to have any chance
to get full custody when many men in
America would take full custody of their
children and not even ask for child
support no the way you're doing the
movie are you transcending race on that
because that is a male
because I got yes probably just as equal
in the white community right yeah I have
plenty of white males who were on the
streets and now I went all across the
United States and many of them talked
about how society was messing them up
one guy I we helped him out to my show
he was looking for two thousand dollars
just to get a car because they had we're
going to repo his old car he's gonna for
to pay for it he was married either
divorce had two children he was getting
from his check he was getting a total of
fifty one dollars after they took off so
he couldn't even afford a car and while
he put up his GoFundMe has been up five
months when I found it he had three
hundred and seventy 5.5 months when he
was just asking for a drive around car
because they were going to take his car
within three days we got him eight
thousand dollars and this is a white guy
and he was struggling because he said
his wife and she left she took the kids
and went to another state he hadn't seen
them in years
and this is the story that a lot of men
are telling black white or other but no
one cares that these men can't see their
kids they say well just keep fighting
you should spend all of your money to
keep fighting this guy a one-gallon
movie went from living in a mansion to
live in the studio apartment after the
divorce wife still lives in the mansion
but he has to pay the same amount of
money he was paying two years ago even
though his job got downgraded because
the judge says you have the potential to
make that money so I'm not going to
change how much you'll pay on top
support well well is it it's powerful
stuff and I love doing this because I
think a lot of it flips conventional
thinking on its head which is what most
people need a little bit of because
people are so locked into the way they
think so let's get you back on when the
movie comes out for sure right and we'll
keep the conversation going and for you
guys hopefully his YouTube channel still
exists by the time we post this but if
youtube.com slash sotomayor tb2 or or
yeah go take it away yes or you guys can
find me on my website which they haven't
figured out a way to take down man etc
my yo tv.com or just Tommy Sotomayor
calm and it will take you to me don't it
done
[Music]
you